et y est pas encore là vous est-ce que
vous aimiez l'émission est ce que vous
critiquez dit la vérité
non j'ai aimé l'émission jamais
l'émission et j'ai franchement j'aurais
un jour ma et croisez dans la rue on
m'avait proposé
c'est vrai on se connaissait pas c'est
vrai qu'on s'est croisé dans la rue soit
vous êtes venus vers mons et croiser au
milieu d'une rue et voilà un vélib
pourquoi tu ne viendrais pas chez moi je
vous avais pris mon numéro vous m'avez
rappeler est en fait j'en rêvais c'est
vrai et j'en rêvais donc vous avez
accompli mon rêve est la septième saison
7e et dont on pressent que vous vivez un
bonheur au quotidien dit la vérité dont
j'adore je m'occuperai c'est vrai que
c'est une émission qui est quotidienne
qui voit la ccca c'est le toque
chauffard mine de rien or et on est très
regardée est ce que c'est une trop
grosse pression pour vous c'est une
question que jamais envie de vous poser
est ce que vraiment vous dites c'est
vrai que tp mpc au quotidien c'est quand
même une grosse pression mathieu tu le
sais pas moi je sais très bien que h2o
on m'appelle le gourcuff de tpm paie
donc quoi abbas qu'elle est maman je
joue pis je suis blessé puis vient une
semaine
il revient alors franchement là c'est
dur ouais vraiment c est bien comme tous
y aller le bout très bon côté de la
chose et puis il ya les moments il est
moins bon côté parce qu'en fait sans
s'en rendre compte on est jugée du matin
au soir entre twitter les gens les
journalistes les gens qui regardent
l'émission après l'émission quand tu
rentres chez toi tu as une sale tête de
la fatigue et était drôle d'être assis
ce n'était pas drôle de machin pita
famille qui forme une couche ce n'était
pas bon ce soir tu en as trop mis un
machin tu es jugé du matin au soir et
parfois envie de dire ce que ça vous
touche très mature moment où vous dites
c'est trop quotidien ccdh yens c'est dur
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup c'est
parfois que je demande à entendre lever
un petit peu le pied et parfois vous me
dites oui enfin ça vous fait chier on me
dit voilà oui c'est vrai quand même vrai
qu'on s'amuse beaucoup et puis on a un
travail merveilleux donc on va surtout
pas se plaindre mais vous êtes quelqu'un
de très exigeant et donc vous demander
comment s'en sortir alors du dégât
gros connard
vous dites moi non mais dites moi tout
travaillé énormément parce que vous ne
supportez pas de notre part la moins de
médiocrité donc parfois on veut dire
qu'ils les valeurs dont l'émission n'est
pas besoin de nous ça déroule mais
parfois vous appuyez sur nous si on
n'est pas au niveau là ça va pas donc
c'est vrai on se plaint surtout pas mais
c'est de la pression c'est un travail
qui est fait de bosser dans ce bel
isabelle et la manger une fierté
vous me parlez toujours de rtl et de m6
mais figurez-vous que dans toutes les
petites affaires qui nous ont agité et
je vous ai été d'une fidélité que je
regrette pas que j'adore j'ai refusé et
de donner des informations sur les haies
de faire des papiers à charge et de
faire du papier a valu de rester ici
surtout ira bien sûr vous m'avez
toujours fasciné je vous ai toujours
trouvé autant d'énigmes télévisuelles
comme ça sort de rock star du paf
mais est-ce que c'est dur à partir non
moi je trouve que c'est vraiment pas dur
je trouve qu'on est immense privilégier
la cie mais non c'est pas démago je
trouve qu'on a quand même qu'il avait
résisté agréable il ya une très bonne
ambiance on est quand même une belle
bande après effectivement il ya des
thématiques qui sont extrêmement
clémente aujourd'hui on peut plus
tellement parlé avec une liberté
d'expression mais malgré tout et c'est
triste à dire on ne peut pas dire ce
qu'on veut à la télé aujourd'hui mais
pas de votre fait à vous parce que vous
me dit toujours de dire ce qu'on veut
mais il ya des thématiques aujourd'hui
qui hystérise complètement le débat et
ça c'est dommage effectivement on peut
après si on est plus ou moins fragile le
prend mal
sinon enfin fini si on peut dire ce
qu'on veut ah oui si géraldine on peut
dire ce qu'on veut mais jamais vous nous
imposez le cas si vous avez des petits
coups de moins bien parfois dit la
vérité
ça peut arriver sur ces procédures au
quotidien à ce qu on fait comme si on
vous voyez pas les réseaux sociaux ont
dit ah bon je regarde pas je suis plus
forte que ça est en fait au final bas
peut pas s'empêcher on va quand même
voir les raison sur une chose sur ce qui
vous dérange qui blessent oui parce que
dans la rue c'est gentil est
généralement wade joue mais derrière
l'ordinateur sait moins c'est moins de
fulham c'est le far west à peupler le
rythme on peut dire puisque vous êtes là
tous les jours une brème ouais bon après
c'est vrai que le rythme quotidien c'est
tous les jours c'est assez éprouvant
mais le quand on arrive ici
en fait on peut être fatiguée la journée
et dès qu'on arrive ici on donne dans
une humeur ou donnant lieu à une sorte
de bulle d'oxygène
et puis moi j'ai besoin d'amour je sois
trop d'amour de tout le monde parce que
j'aime j'aime tout le monde autour de
cette table et je me suis vraiment
attaché voix jean-louis franchement toi
qui bossent pas du tout je suis pas
celui qui bosse le plus son armée
motlanthe a tout connu avec moi tu étais
le seul rescapé de la première est la
première c'est vrai que ça a évolué dans
le temps et c'est vrai que depuis deux
ans à peu près six mois qu'avait
l'habitude d'être un peu le pas le
bouffon mais celui qui parle est un peu
le cul comme ça de façon assez libre
j'ai changé un vrai changement
du coup maintenant j'ose plus reparlé
même j'ai eu une certaine émission j'ai
eu peur de dire des choses qui pouvaient
choquer et c'est parce que ça m'a valu
des soucis donc cet excellent rythme
physiquement tout c'est ce que c'est dur
ou pas ça serait ça serait un ca serait
indigne chambre de dire que c'est
fatigant serra qui travaillent heures
par jour ça monsieur salon quoi ce
serait un 10-2 dire c'est plutôt
moralement psychologiquement ça peut
être un peu stressant parfois parce que
vous mettez ainsi la pression et c'est
normal vous êtes le chef c'est grâce à
vous si halak grâce à pression vous
mettez copil la locomotive
j'ai l'impression
mais c'est une pression positive
franchement ma vous mais je vous mettais
de la pression à l'équipe mais en
général mais pas mais c'est bien cette
pression parce que diouf outre les bébés
on sait que tu es nadal donc si on
baisse un tout petit peu au trône on se
prend une balle sur la ligne
il n'habite pas demandé son avis
moi j'ai pas là j'ai pas mal
d'expérience donc je vis ça me
pleinement et j'ai aucune pression on
s'entend très bien donc
et j'ai vécu des choses tellement
différente qui s'est subitement je suis
très heureux et je connais tu mangeais
pas de pression et ma relation avec vous
du jour regarder aujourd'hui franchement
c'est vrai que moi j'ai plein des
mécanismes pardon j'ai plein de
journalistes qui me disent des cons mais
touche pas à mon poste
voilà sur un article sur touche pas à
mon poste ou des combes et votre nom
mine de rien on fait exprès de faire des
articles mauvais parce qu'on va faire
déclic alors qu'on a rien contre vous
ben oui m
l'important c'est que quand j'ai
commencé l'émission moi j'avais une
image un peu je passais un peu pour un
prétentieux steira j'avais pas forcément
bien communiquer et elle pour un beauf
et non pardon à merde ils m'ont frappé
il va alors il va rentrer de nom et
c'est vrai que ça ça d'aider des gens d
re découvert un bep à benji qui ne
connaissais pas je pense que le medic je
suis au plateau c'est ce que je suis
dans la salle ça m'a fait beaucoup de
bien pour ça maxime chez mais aussi bien
amusé l'émission sur france 4
tout le monde est vraiment sur des huit
ans alors ce que ça a basculé en direct
vous pouvez pas vous imaginer à quel
point lorsque vous annonciez des prime
où le rendez vous que c'était j'ai
regardé un replay j'ai regardé les et
qu'il y avait toujours quelque chose qui
se passe c'est parce que dans cette
émission certainement le média et peut
tout se passer n'importe quel moment
mais c'est vrai plus que jamais et
aujourd'hui moi je ressens plus de
l'exaltation au quotidien et
effectivement on peut avoir les coups de
mou dans la journée mais dès qu'on
arrivait ici et là le taux d'adrénaline
qui remonte et on est prêt pour faire le
meilleur spectacle qui soit parce que
c'est des divertissements et grâce à
vous êtes un peu le moteur de toute
cette émission merci encore
merci encore
alors vous avez parlé vous avez parlé de
coup de mou ces projets qui me tourner
vers des banques toi ça va depuis que tu
arrives est arrivé depuis maintenant un
mois
en fait ce que les jantes en parle
beaucoup dans la rue énormément ça on te
dit quoi réveille-toi c'est tout on me
parle énormément de de notre duo en fait
de l'effet qu'on a parce que comme je
suis je fréquente plus on va dire les
gens peu du terrain de la rue comme on
dit chez nous et ça leur fait énormément
plaisir de voir ensemble 2 antin on nous
demande de dire la halle bonjour un peu
à tout le 93 le 95 de 70 77 91 30 15
c'est ya ya de l'amour un peu qui vient
de du terrain de la base énorme merci à
toi qui étais une journaliste lci tout
ça est au tapis a dit que tu vas faire
complètement moi j'ai fait le grand
écart et ya des gens qui m'ont dit mais
qu'est ce que tu as fait hacher hanouna
mais pour moi je relativise parce que
quand je suis arrivé au cs ans m'a dit
qu'est ce que tu allais faire au csa
donc je suis et c'est mon choix je suis
très content j'ai découvert une machine
incroyable très professionnelle derrière
les rires les sourires être beaucoup de
professionnalité beaucoup de créativité
et je crois que s'il faut résumer en un
mot c'est la capacité d'adaptation pour
réussir à tenir même un an à vos côtés
et je suis avec l'équipe
non mais c'est vrai faut s'adapter à
tout moment on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer même sur les cinq minutes qui
viennent
et ça je n'avais jamais vu ça avant donc
chapeau l'artiste d'avoir pu nous réunir
avec des profils différents
j'écoute arrêta j'écoute vraiment calme
toi chérie et
et voilà et moi vraiment je me suis mise
en danger j'ai testé mes capacités
d'adaptation et je suis très fier d'être
avec vous
depuis un an et avec toute l'équipe
depuis un peu plus d'un an très
clairement on est très content je
voulais rien de l'histoire est très très
heureux très heureux aléas mais quoi le
garage de griffo icrt grille